what is going on Marvel fans welcome
back to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren
Thompson and a lot of stuff is happening
over at Marvel Studios right now today
we're going to be going over news about
the Silver Surfer Nova and the new
Avengers and it's important to note that
it does seem like Marvel Studios has a
lot of big announcements upcoming this
year it really does seem like this is
the year that Marvel is kind of taking a
step back evaluating everything that
they've done and are about to do in
Phase 5 and Phase 6 and you have
probably heard me mention recently in
one of our recent videos that Marvel and
Disney Kevin fogy and Bob Iger are
really making sure everything is up to a
certain quality and standard before they
release things now the reason I keep
mentioning this is because it is
becoming more and more relevant every
single day and we'll talk about that
today as a certain project that I know a
lot of us myself included are waiting
for and are really wanting to happen
well that project is going to rely on
another project first first depending
how that project does will determine
whether this new one gets made or not
we'll talk about all of this in this
video and if you're new and you love
Marvel be sure to subscribe to the
channel so you don't miss out on any of
the latest videos we're doing a giveaway
as well we'll talk more about that at
the end so yesterday Alex Perez over at
the cosmic circus.com an extremely
reliable Insider did a Q&A on his
Discord server the Discord for the
cosmic circus and answered a bunch of
questions about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and as I mentioned he talked
about Nova the Silver Surfer the new
Avengers and the midnight Suns which we
will talk about in this video that's
that specific project that I mentioned
but the first thing he had to say about
Nova was pretty interesting he stated
that if Nova isn't announced during San
Diego ComicCon or d23 this year it's
most likely not happening during this
Saga and he did say that the project was
still in the writing phases right now so
it's being written it's being worked on
right now there's not a finalized script
but they are working on it now now Alex
peover at the cosmic circus reported
that a Nova special presentation was in
the works a while ago they also reported
it about the Silver Surfer which we'll
talk about next but it's very
interesting that Marvel Studios hasn't
officially decided whether to include
Nova in the Multiverse Saga yet or not
but remember Marvel Studios is doing a
lot of rewrites for a lot of different
projects and one of those projects is
Avengers 5 what used to be referred to
as Avengers King Dynasty and these
rewrites don't just affect the project
that is being Rewritten but they affect
the MCU overall because of course
everything is connected even though it
hasn't seemed like that so much recently
but another thing that's pretty
interesting is that Alex Perez said
something that a lot of other insiders
and actual big media Outlets have been
talking about and that is that Marvel
Studios seems to have some pretty big
plans for San Diego ComicCon and d23
this year remember they didn't really do
anything last year no really big
announcements happened and we now know
that it's because Bob Iger and Kevin
fige like I've been talking about have
kind of taken a step back to re-evaluate
everything and they've determin that
they pretty much will not make something
if one it doesn't make sense and two it
doesn't have a good story so with Nova I
think right now for Marvel Studios it's
all about finding a really great spot to
introduce him they won't give Nova his
own special presentation unless they
have found another project to insert him
in and from what we've heard about
Avengers 5 the new Avengers movie it
doesn't sound like like it's going to be
too Cosmic it sounds like it's going to
be pretty grounded like it's going to be
kind of a street level Avengers film so
that doesn't really seem to be the place
that Nova would show up also to
introduce him in a special presentation
and then just randomly have him show up
in Avengers Secret Wars probably
wouldn't do too much Justice to the
character he'd probably have to be
involved in another storyline before
Secret Wars to have a decent role in
secret Wars but this is a really good
thing that means Marvel Studios is being
very very peculiar and intentional with
what they do now so they can do justice
to these characters the Silver Surfer is
another one of those like I mentioned
Alex P reported a long time ago that the
Silver Surfer was coming to the MCU he
was supposed to be one of the Heralds of
galatis who was the villain of the
Fantastic 4 film and the Silver Surfer
before debuting in the Fantastic 4 film
was getting his own special presentation
unfortunately we have a little bit of an
update that is a different report now he
States when he reported on a Silver
Surfer special coming to Disney plus
Silver Surf was going to be galactus's
Herald in the Fantastic 4 film he now
says that is no longer the case so if
the special is still happening it won't
be like his initial report now if you've
been keeping up with Fantastic 4 News
you probably know why this isn't the
case anymore it's been reported that the
Silver Surfer in the Fantastic 4 movie
is going to be a female Silver Surfer
widely believed to probably be Juno or a
version of Frankie Ray and this was
reported by Jeff Snyder now I've seen
that this has kind of made a lot of
people mad but I have also talked about
before how Grace Randolph reported that
the Fantastic 4 film might take place in
Another Universe not the main 616
universe and if this happens then this
could work rather well if their Universe
ends up getting destroyed from either an
incursion or by galatis and the Silver
Surfer and they are taken from their
universe and brought to our universe
just the Fantastic for team and their
families then after Avengers Secret Wars
we could get the norn rad Silver Surfer
that we all know and love so there are
ways to make this work and if this is
their plan I have to say it's actually
pretty creative and I wouldn't mind it
if we ultimately do get the classic
noren rad Silver Surfer I think a lot of
fans including myself would really love
that the good news is for Nova and the
Silver Surfer is that Marvel Studios
clearly has some plans to include them
whether that's in this Saga or the next
he then also said something pretty
interesting about a lot of characters of
The New Avengers he said that Captain
Marvel Captain Rambo Ant-Man and wasp
will be redeemed for audiences in their
next appearances like Thor in Infinity
War recent reports have told us that
Captain Marvel Ant-Man and the wasp and
a few others are going to be a part of
the new Avengers team we haven't heard
anything about Captain Rambo being a
part of the new Avengers team but since
they gave us that post credit scene with
her from the Marvels we know that that
story has to be picked up again and
concluded in one way or another now he
didn't mention if they were going to be
redeemed in the New Avengers film
Avengers 5 or in Avengers Secret Wars
but again since we know that these
characters are going to be a part of the
new Avengers team most of them we can
assume that the Redemption starts with
the new Avengers in that movie plus not
to mention it's been reported that
Ant-Man is going to show up in
Spider-Man 4 so clearly these characters
that he mentioned Marvel Studios has big
plans for them and they seem to be kind
of rethinking how they used them before
since Ant-Man and the WASP quantam Mania
was not very well received and the same
thing goes with the Marvels both movies
were pretty big letdowns to both the
studio and to a lot of fans if you like
those movies fantastic I'm happy for you
but MoneyWise they really didn't perform
for the studio and again them having a
Redemption meaning they're going to have
some scenes and a story throughout the
entire Multiverse Saga leading up to
Secret Wars and incret Wars that'll make
the fans just really be in awe of what
is happening like how Thor landed in
wakanda with rocket and Groot with
Stormbreaker that was an epic moment
them getting Redemption arcs like that
is showing us that Marvel Studio really
is re-evaluating everything and trying
to do some damage control right now for
these characters who are loved by a lot
of people and the fact that Marvel
Studios is doing this is also shown in
another report from Alex P and this one
is in regards to the midnight Suns he
states that while there are early ideas
for the midnight Suns they are
contingent on the success of Blade which
is kind of scary to think about because
blade has undergone so many different
script rewrites however like we reported
yesterday it does seem like they have
locked down a new script and everybody
seems pretty happy with it and based off
of what we heard it does sound like it's
going to be a pretty good story if
executed properly but again this shows
that Marvel Studios really is trying to
only produce quality content and that is
shown here by Alex's report if Marvel
Studios produces blade and it's not
received well they're not going to
double down and create another project
that's very similar that also has blade
in it just for it to Flap as well
remember the studios they need to make
money that's what the shareholders care
about that's what the board of directors
care about they are businesses and yes
we love them because they produce a lot
of great things that we love and I truly
believe that there are people there like
Kevin feige who just want to make really
great things for the fans but these
things kind of go hand inhand with each
other if Marvel Studios and Disney want
to make money and the way that they
believe to do that is to make quality
content which is right by the way and
that leads to them not producing crappy
projects then that's kind of a win-win
for everybody I say kind of because if
blade does fail and we don't get a
midnight Suns I'm going to be pretty
bummed cuz I really want the midnight
suns in the MCU but the great thing is
is it sounds like Marvel Studios right
now really is kind of taking all the
measures that they can to make sure that
all the projects that they are putting
out are good they are rewriting so many
different projects right now and they
are making sure that they are good so
it's a good time for the MCU right now
as weird as that sounds I know a lot of
people are kind of tired with what
they've been doing lately but it does
sound like they really are trying to
revamp everything and make Marvel
Studios kind of what it used to be where
they would release hit after hit after
hit after hit so that's exciting and
hopefully everything we get from them is
going to be very good moving forward but
go ahead and let me know what you think
about all of this news in the comments
down below Nova Silver Surfer the new
Avengers and blade and the midnight Suns
don't forget to like this video And
subscribe stay up to date on the MCU and
if you leave a comment and subscribe
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 and
Xbox series X Marvel Legends items or
some DC items the winner gets to pick
and we pick one winner at the end of
each month you can find us on Instagram
and Twitter /x and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof
woof